[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: Hello, I'm Dan
Galpin for "The Developer
Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Fast Pair is a set of
specs that make it easier
to connect Bluetooth headsets
and speakers to Android
devices.
And we recently made
it easier for users
to connect Fast-Pair-compatible
accessories to devices
associated with the
same Google account.
Fast Pair will
connect accessories
to a user's current and
future Android phones
with Android 6.0 and higher.
And we're adding support
for Chromebooks in 2019.
For more info, or to make your
device Fast-Pair-compatible,
take a look at the post linked
in the description below.
If you develop an SDK
or library for Android,
you can now register
with us to receive
updates to keep you informed
about Google Play policy
changes, updates
to the platform,
and other useful information.
The form is linked
from the post.
The Asia-Pacific market is
important for Google Cloud.
In the past 18
months, we've expanded
the number of GCP regions
there from three to six.
The sixth APAC region was just
opened this week in Hong Kong,
with another coming
to Jakarta, Indonesia.
For more details,
and to get started,
head on over to the post.
The Crashlytics
integration with BigQuery
gives you the freedom to
deeply explore your data.
With Data Studio, you can
make custom dashboards
from your Crashlytics
data that fit
the unique way your team works.
We recently launched
the Data Studio template
to give you a peek at what's
possible with Crashlytics
and BigQuery.
For screenshots, and to get
started with the template,
head on over to the post.
Chrome 72 is now available in
the dev channel with DevTools
updates, including the ability
to visualize performance
metrics in the
Performance panel,
highlight text notes
in the DOM tree,
copy the JS path to a DOM node
from the DOM tree, and more.
For all the details,
take a look at the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Dan Galpin for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
(BRITISH ACCENT) Fast
Pair is a set of specs
that make it easier to
connect Bluetooth headsets.
SPEAKER: Can we just
do a regular voice?
DAN GALPIN: (BRITISH
ACCENT) Oh, come on.
Come on, everyone loves it.
You know, people they--
when you actually
use this sort of
voice, they listen.
It's-- it's proven.